[Musica]
la montagna questa straordinaria
capacità di affascinare affascinato
scrittori viaggiatori per i suoi colori
per le sue forme per i suoi profumi per
i paesaggi
io vivo e lavoro o questa fortuna di
studiare la montagna è un ambiente
quando ci si pensa nel definirlo non è
così semplice che cos'è la montagna la
montagna realtà è una combinazione tra
quota ma anche la pendenza la pendenza
che crea una grossa energia delle
rilievo e questa energia del rilievo si
può tradurre in movimento e quindi dalla
combinazione di quote pendenza nasce un
ambiente unico un ambiente che copre il
22 per cento delle terre emerse il 15
per cento della popolazione mondiale
vive in montagna
quindi un ambiente straordinario unico
ovviamente questa energia del rilievo ha
obbligato l'uomo che voleva vivere in
montagna contrastarla in qualche modo e
quindi l'elogio delle superfici piatte
lavorare per avere superfici piatte con
i terrazzamenti avere dei luoghi in cui
questa energia di rilievo in qualche
modo potesse essere mitigata renderla
adatta alla vita dell'uomo nonostante
questo obiettivamente è un ambiente
difficile spesso si è lontani dai
servizi essenziali
questa è un'immagine in nepal questi
scolari eleganti magari due ore di
cammino per raggiungere la scuola non
parliamo degli ospedali qui tante volte
un ambiente in qualche modo ostile un
ambiente pero ricche di risorse
aria pura legno e soprattutto acqua il
70 per cento dell'acqua dolce del nostro
pianeta si trova in montagna è una
quantità straordinaria e crea una
connessione con le aree di pianura che
spesso beneficiano di questo capitale
che la montagna rende disponibile anche
a chilometri di distanza
quest'acqua può trovarsi come si vede in
questa immagine anche allo stato solido
ghiaccio neve
viviamo in un pianeta straordinario in
cui possiamo avere l'acqua allo stato
liquido solido e vapore non è una cosa
rara e degli altri pianeti questo non
può avvenire
ghiaccio neve così come il ghiaccio
marino sono tutti elementi della
criosfera la criosfera questa parte del
nostro pianeta in cui l'acqua è presente
allo stato solido e magnifico le
molecole si ordinano e si crea il
ghiaccio e questa superficie ricoperta
dall'acqua lo stato solido e proprio
l'atmosfera e noi la vediamo lo possiamo
apprezzare dai satelliti ma a volte la
criosfera è nascosta un po timida come
il permafrost e il nostro stand
substrato gelato in cui l'acqua è
congelata ma che sta sotto i nostri
piedi io lo studio in siberia ad elevata
latitudine in alaska
ma posso studiarla anche in montagna ad
alta quota
nell'esposizione nord in cui o
camminando posso muovermi sul ghiaccio
senza accorgermene
a volte il perno fossi palesa
magicamente e mette in movimento le
pietre può sembrare incredibile
le pietre e assumiamo come qualcosa di
stabile che non si muovano il gelo il di
gelo in certe condizioni
trasporta le pietre a formare dei cerchi
come questo se ne possono contare tanti
ci sono dei luoghi sulle altre ad
esempio in cui si trovano questi cerchi
ed è di nuovo la natura che si mette in
movimento a causa del ghiaccio
poi la neve la neve un altro
straordinario elemento della criosfera
la neve protegge il suolo durante
l'inverno è un elemento magico a un
certo punto di vista la neve può
muoversi le valanghe una valanga
polverosa può raggiungere velocità di
300 km all'ora
pressioni di tonnellate a metro quadrato
tutta l'energia del rilievo la neve che
si mette movimento e può creare di nuovo
delle situazioni particolari
io ho la fortuna di poter studiare la
montagna di studiare la neve sono un
rivolo go e in particolare per me
studiare la neve significa coglierne il
fascino cercare di coglierne i
cambiamenti e per farlo non ho bisogno
di grandi attrezzature
una lastrina una lente di pochi
ingrandimenti la fortuna di poter vivere
una 20enne vato e cercare di riconoscere
i cristalli cristalli sono lettere dal
cielo si formano nelle nubi in un
ambiente completamente diverso
scendono al suolo sono in una situazione
che non è come quella della nube devono
trasformarsi iniziano a cambiare e noi
con la lente cerchiamo di riconoscerli
cambiano di giorno in giorno direi quasi
in ora in ora e attraverso
riconoscimento noi percepiamo queste
trasformazioni che sono detti
metamorfismi e sono qualcosa di
estremamente interessante e affascinante
quando uno pensa alla neve poi dice un
qualcosa di freddo sia fredda ma è
invece molto molto ospitale ci sono
organismi estremofili come queste alghe
adattati a vivere al freddo adattati a
vivere la neve e anche loro si palesano
in primavera in cui si riconosce questo
colore rosso un rosso sangue quasi un po
macabro e quest'alga che si protegge con
un pigmento rosso dalla radiazione
solare come fossero a crema solare e
compie il suo ciclo di vita proprio
all'interno del manto nevoso è un rosso
molto più vivo di questo marroncino
tenue
questo invece è quando non sulle alpi
sull'appennino arrivano le deposizioni
sahariane
piccole particelle di linea gila che
percorrono migliaia di chilometri e
vanno a depositarsi dentro la neve
trasformando trasportando con sé
minerali microfossili che arrivano in
questo caso dalle regioni sahariane
quindi la neve che diventa una big
qual è il problema alla montagna la neve
il ghiaccio sono elementi fragili pochi
variazioni di temperatura anche modeste
ne possono pregiudicare l'esistenza le
montagne si stanno scaldando si stanno
scaldando di più che la media del nostro
pianeta e questo le rende ancora più
vulnerabile questo riscaldamento
che noi conosciamo che abbiamo imparato
a conoscere sta avvenendo con ritmi che
mai si sono verificati un'accelerazione
e quindi in qualche modo la natura la
montagna si mette in movimento le specie
vegetali salgono di quota
i ghiacciai reagiscono come guardate
questa immagine questa è un ghiacciaio
con una linea immaginaria la villa di
equilibrio che separa la zona più alta
in cui la neve si trasforma in ghiaccio
alimentandolo la parte più bassa in cui
invece la neve il ghiaccio fondono cosa
sta succedendo questa linea si sta
alzando quindi è sempre minore la
superficie in cui il ghiaccio si può
formare rispetto la superficie in cui
ghiaccio può fondere come reagiscono i
ghiacciai non sono più in equilibrio
reagiscono arretrando questo un
ghiacciaio del lys a cui sono molto
affezionato nel monte rosa a sinistra
un'immagine 1920 raccolta scattata da
umberto monti ricordatevi questo nome
ne parlerò anche dopo
e adesso dopo 100 anni una foto dallo
stesso punto di presa di arnold ed una
guida alpina che mi ha donato molte di
queste fotografie e i confronti
fotografici parlano da sé i ghiacciai
funzionano per comunicare il
riscaldamento globale in cent'anni più
di un chilometro di sviluppo del
ghiacciaio spessori anche di 40 50 metri
milioni di metri cubi di ghiaccio che si
sono persi acqua preziosa e quindi dal
punto di vista dell'impatto queste
immagini vogliono dire molto certo
bisogna avere immagini storiche
l'importanza quindi di avere
testimonianze anche di un tempo che
adesso non c'è più tutti i termini la
forza delle parole
anticipo accelerazioni arretramento
fusioni innalzamento aumento sono tutte
parole che noi cerchiamo di indagare le
parole hanno un significato per noi
significa capire le cause i meccanismi
gli effetti di questi mutamenti
e lo facciamo con una logica che quello
della condivisione nello spazio le reti
di ricerca questa è la rete il terra
quindi cui faccio parte per la ricerca
ecologica lungo termine tutti questi
puntini sono dei punti in cui ci sono
dei siti di ricerca in cui cerchiamo di
condurre una ricerca ecologica lungo
termine monitoriamo i parametri di anno
in anno di mese in mese per avere delle
serie continua di dati e questo del
fatto di avere serie continua ci obbliga
andare indietro anche nel tempo quindi
una condivisione dell'informazione nello
spazio ma anche nel tempo e scoprire
vite straordinarie di scienziati che
hanno iniziato a fare misura in tempi in
cui non era così consueto umberto
montani io sono affezionato questo
scienziato dei primi del novecento una
persona straordinaria o poi dedicato
tantissimo del mio tempo fa mi ha
ispirato molto
lui era un glaciologo misurava lo stato
dei ghiacciai vi dicevo primi del
novecento
una spedizione addirittura nel sahara
africano ne sarà libico nel 1934
adattare la sua curiosità e dal deserto
di ghiaccio si muova il deserto di
sabbia un climatologo dirige una rete di
osservatori sulle alpi in cui a partire
dal 1925 al 1940 inizia a misurare la
neve il vento le precipitazioni e lo fa
raccogliendo
400mila dati in 15 anni dati che adesso
sono preziosi perché noi possiamo
confrontare i nostri dati con i dati che
ha raccolto lui più 80 100 anni fa
era talmente la sua ansia di conoscenza
la sua curiosità che riteneva
inconcepibile che si potesse andare in
montagna per puro piacere come tu va in
montagna e cosa dice in questo
manualetto distruzione scientifiche per
alpinisti del cai alpinista che va in
montagna se avrà occasione di osservare
della pioggia di sopra di 3.500 metri
durante la stagione estiva di cura di
prenderne note di darmene comunicazione
è un evento raro veder piovere sopra dei
3500 metri adesso probabilmente dovremmo
dire alpinista se vedi piovere sopra i
4.000 metri ma non è tanto questo che mi
premeva raccontare ma il fatto di
coinvolgere il non esperto nella ricerca
scientifica
lui è stato un precursore anche in
questo
in quella che viene conosciuto come la
citizen science il fatto in qualche modo
in cui si coinvolga il non esperto in
una ricerca scientifica
una ricerca quindi partecipata
qui vi ho messo questa esperienza questi
cammini el terre ci siamo mossi dal
monte rosa al lago maggiore una serie di
scienziati di esperti con gruppi di
persone che si univano a noi durante il
cammino la meraviglia di camminare poter
condividere i paesaggi e condividere
abbiamo raccolti dati gli abbiamo
elaborati le abbiamo trasmesso avevo
discusso ed era stato uno straordinario
modo quello della citizen psystar ad
avvicinare tutti alla scienza capirne i
limiti capirne il fascino la meraviglia
capire cos'è una comunità scientifica
una comunità in cui come vi dicevo le
idee circolano si muovono nello spazio
nel tempo fatte di vite di ricercatori e
ricercatrici che spendono la loro vita
che sono animate tutte da una parola che
io adoro la curiosità la curiosità avere
un obiettivo comune e cercare di
coglierlo insieme e quindi l'idea
insomma di questa condivisione
soprattutto di questi tempi una
condivisione che non ha confini né di
stati né di discipline lo trovo un'idea
la trovo un'idea meravigliosa e quindi
in questo momento non posso che dirvi
grazie per avermi dato questa
opportunità
e chiudo con un'immagine ora quale sono
affezionato
uno dei miei parti giochi preferiti
questo l'istituto scientifico angelo
mosso dell'università di torino ha 3000
m tra piemonte valle d'aosta dove la
fortuna di poter giocare e soddisfare
alcune delle mie curiosità
grazie ancora
[Applauso]